[Música]
helmand y ver es un empresario
ecuatoriano que ha trabajado activamente
en la introducción y promoción del
código abierto en ecuador fundador de
palosanto solutions empresa desde la
cual ha generado varios proyectos
después de gobierno particularmente
elastix recientemente está involucrado
en el movimiento makers fundando así el
lapse una iniciativa destinada a
establecer centros de desarrollo de
productos y prototipos empezando con el
primer fat lab en la espol
bueno llegó el día
les cuento que antes de llegar aquí no
tenía las horas no tenía aún clara la
charla el tema que iba a darnos entonces
hablé un poco con el comité organizador
les di algunos títulos que tenía
pensé un poco para mis adentros fue una
maraña mental hasta que encontré un
título que me pareció genial y dije
bueno este es el look si super título
el nuevo ver de los tests entonces se
los conté al comité organizador y me
dijeron
la conseja así el título es nuevos
espacios y ahí tú sabrás qué hacer
entonces con esa respuesta yo le valió
madres mi súper actitud lo que era cómo
tomar decisiones basados en la intuición
pero me hizo ver algo interesante y es
que a lo mejor lo que me distingue de la
mayoría
es la manera como yo he hecho negocios
en mi vida y fue como una revelación
entender de que mucha gente no esperaba
que hable de otra cosa aunque me
pareciera muy chévere sino que hable
precisamente de cómo he hecho negocios
en mi vida porque lo mejor es diferente
y yo viviendo lo día a día no me he dado
cuenta un poco del impacto de eso
entonces se lo voy a explicar de una
manera muy íntima como incidencia fui a
mi facebook
en la madrugada de antes de ayer y me
puse a secar todas las fotos que
encontré que tengan que ver con este
tema no entonces el negocio de compartir
de qué se trata de qué se trata de esto
no podemos nunca nunca se enteraran de
lo que le iba a decir con mi súper
charlas y mi súper tema pero creo que sí
me ha gustado lo que se me ocurrió
después
entonces compartir conocimiento en un
delito cuando somos niños en la casa nos
enseña a compartir comparte con tu primo
apretar los juguetes de tu hermano y nos
dicen esa serie de cosas todos los días
y el no compartir es malo
entonces si no compartes con tu un año
porque no le presta en la boca te a
túnez cuando ya crecemos sucede que los
juguetes comienzan a resultar más caros
y ya no es fácil decir bueno comparte el
carro a tu primo o presta de la moto al
vecino y cuando ya estamos en el mundo
laboral
sucede que pasa totalmente lo contrario
ya la sociedad no se ha hecho muy
celosos con el conocimiento
tanto así que si uno tiene una idea
buena lo que sea a todo nivel alguien
hace un plato delicioso y sabe ser un
postre genial y quiere abrir una
pastelería le dicen oye pero no le digas
a nadie la receta porque ese estudio
diferenciador
entonces hemos llegado al punto en que
no necesariamente pretendemos que
alguien vaya donde nosotros porque somos
los mejores sino porque somos los únicos
porque no hay opción que nadie más sabe
mi receta y eso se da en todos los
ámbitos del mundo de negocios también se
da en la música alguien crea una música
la registra y nadie más puede tocar la
música sin mi permiso así ella un fulano
que pueda hacerlo mejor así venga
alguien más que pueda elaborar uno sea
más talentoso que yo no importa todo
está restringido a lo que yo hice y
registre y eso lo que tiene mucho mucho
mucho el momento de mejorar es decir una
vez que un producto se patenta y ya
nadie puede tomar ese conocimiento para
mejorarlo eso se vuelve un estancamiento
en la innovación y así pasa como lo
encontraba la industria de la música si
quiero abrir un restaurante pero también
pasa en la industria farmacéutica y ahí
es más grave
hay un nombre que no lo voy a mencionar
pero que le doy un tip en internet
el nombre más odiado de internet y
entonces lo que hizo el fulano es es un
tipo de negocios sabe obviamente lo que
hace a nivel de dinero compró una
empresa farmacéutica
aún más preciosa empresas vendían una
pastilla para la diarrea que costaba 13
dólares
se vendía en todo el mundo una
iniciativa también ha llevado a países
en desarrollo
donde hay gente pobre incluso subsidiada
la pastilla que se diga esa medicación
una vez que el tipo de quirió la empresa
y las patentes inherentes obviamente lo
que hizo el fulano fue subir el precio
de 13 a 750 dólares obviamente eso es un
problema social mucha gente se quedó sin
consumir la pastilla entonces ahí hay
cosas graves que se comienzan a ver en
el industria del software
perdón es donde yo estoy involucrado
muchas empresas gastan más dinero en
pelear patentes o estar en los juzgados
que haciendo investigación en desarrollo
que es lo que nosotros como usuarios no
nos debería interesar incluso empresas
farmacéuticas gastan más en marketing
que en la propia medicina la medicina en
sí eso es grave porque la patente se ha
vuelto un sobre protector de un hombre
de negocios vamos a decirlo si hoy una
empresa de negocios
en el caso de software los juicios son
rimbombantes salen a la luz del día
apple le ganó un juicio a samsung por la
cuestión del del galaxy y le dijo que
había copiado cositas como las curvas en
los bordes de los teléfonos o los iconos
cuadriculados ya llegamos al extremo de
la sobreprotección las sumas son de
miles de millones ahora hay un juicio
entre oracle y google por una razón
similar miles de miles de millones de
dólares que fácilmente nos podrían
aliviar otros problemas mucho muchísimo
más graves para ilustrar un poco que el
compartir ya cuando llegamos al mundo de
negocios se vuelve un poco se
distorsiona eso que nos enseñaron en la
infancia no entonces qué voy a hacer
ahora
yo voy a explicar un poco no me voy a
meter en argumentos muy filosóficos ni
dar fórmulas de por qué compartir es
bueno porque es malo pero les voy a
contar una historia personal
y básicamente en 1999 nosotros creamos
una empresa basada en software libre un
software que se regala
entonces muchos amigos muchos cercanos
nos decían no es no va a funcionar
cuidado normal
chuta no creo que es un socio una vez me
dijo nos vamos a comer la camisa bueno
todavía no sé a qué sabe una camisa pero
les voy a demostrar que no fue
relativamente bien no entonces
esa lámina me la voy a saltar hablé un
poco de eso lo que hicimos un software
llamado de las tics de las tics para
resumir es un pp x un software de
telefonía que decidimos lanzarlo al
mundo gratis el negocio donde estaba el
negocio estaba en hacer negocios
alrededor de un producto gratis dando
servicios entrenamiento soporte técnico
consultoría etcétera el negocio va a ser
tal
hemos tenido representación en europa
oficinas en uruguay en méxico el
producto se distribuye a lo largo y
ancho del planeta y eso es lo que les
quiero enseñar un poco con fotos muy
mías muy personales esto es un poco una
curva de crecimiento desde que lo
creamos como las personas se comenzaron
a descargar el software esta estadística
es hasta el año pasado porque la copia
de una presentación donde alcance
actualizar pero se ve esto no se puede
dar la idea de cómo fue evolucionando y
el impacto de simple compartir es decir
una vez compartido el software
obviamente todo no está en compartir
tienes que tener un producto bueno pero
la idea nuevamente está que no te elijan
por ser el único que te elijan por ser
el mejor es decir yo me voy a comprar
entrenamiento con este fulano porque
escribe el software ya tiene que ser el
adecuado para que me lo dé no me lo voy
a comprar donde la competencia porque él
está copiando entonces un poco esa
filosofía si funciona nosotros llegamos
a crear un evento bueno este año será en
buenos aires todos los años en un país
diferente miles de personas son fotos
reales el último fotos fue en españa un
evento realmente grande la primera foto
fue méxico 2013 la segunda se me fue
pero como ustedes pueden ver instituimos
un evento a nivel mundial que resultó
ser un éxito no mucha gente nos pregunta
vídeos son nosotros ecuatorianos ahí
venía un poco de escepticismo no pero
ecuatorianas asociados con un
norteamericano no somos ecuatorianos
bueno farandulero ahí un poco
llegué escribir un libro
se volvió muy popular de repente yo
estaba firmando autógrafos y me sentía
como una estrella de rock pero chévere
no era el único libro es una foto de la
página de amazon no había otros libros
más como ustedes ven abajo hablando del
tema es decir la gente escribía libros
de repente acerca de nuestro producto
teníamos cursos en irán
en todos los rincones del planeta
llegamos al entrenamiento en dubai sao
paulo madrid toronto francia moscú nueva
york está en bull malasia
y dan miami bueno y nueva york los
ángeles todos los países de
latinoamérica y ciudades
cada curso era un curso
también había el pirata
entonces como nosotros somos una
teníamos la filosofía de compartir no
podíamos decir el curso pirata que no lo
demás estaba dentro de los planes pero
la gente elegía pagar un curso de dos
mil dólares con nosotros a elegir el
curso de 300 dólares con el pirata lo
que les quiero decir nuevamente es no
necesariamente la gente elige al único a
veces la gente elige a quien él cree que
es el mejor posible y esa es la
diferencia entre ser celoso con algo o
no es decir entre decir no no este
software nadie va del código yo lo voy a
guardar en secreto así que están
obligados a comprarme a mí aquí no me
van a elegir porque están obligados me
van a elegir por
que me ganado a lo mejor la reputación
de tener un producto bueno y que lo cree
yo como cuando uno va a un médico y dice
bueno tengo que ir al mejor médico y se
pone a buscar cuál es el mejor médico no
entonces es un poco fue la idea detrás
de este negocio llegamos a ganar premios
internacionales todavía ni uno aquí
todavía espero
pero premios en revistas prestigiosas de
fuera best of soul communication
solución social y ver 2011 internet
teléfono y productos de year 2010 la
revista info word es muy conocida en el
área técnica el premio de 2012-2013 y
bueno era todo un show no hay una
conferencia en el bernabéu
no entiendo mucho qué tiene que ver el
bernabéu con tecnología pero el chévere
me invitaron al congreso a hablar de los
diputados sobre que esto de compartir y
cómo funciona el modelo estaba un poco
intrigados con gobierno también que
porque esto de compartir y fusionar que
si lo podemos replicar en el rey
etcétera
ibarra dios salía en 1 américaeconomía
tv
importada de revista en estaciones de
televisión de otros lados
cnn todos hablando de este modelo de
negocios de compartir que ha generado
millones de dólares como un negocio para
una empresa ecuatoriana entonces era
como una una sorpresa no todo el mundo
interesado en por qué compartir bueno
también nos invitaron a tocar con el
grupo de la ley [ __ ] vecindad a eso
sí no entiendo por qué
pero fue chévere
fue chévere y ahora les voy a explicar
un poco cómo esa buena experiencia ya se
extrapoló a otro nivel
de repente vimos que la industria
también en un país como el nuestro donde
la tecnología el día a día a nivel
industrial todavía seguimos haciendo
procesos muy artesanales mucha gente
compraba muchas empresas compraban
máquinas de alta tecnología
pero esa máquina era el tesoro de la
empresa no se compartía con nadie es
decir si alguien quiere ser la máquina
que me paguen yo no vendo tiempo de
imagen y servicios y los hago con mi
máquina que nadie más tiene nadie más
tiene yo voy a hacer que un gran negocio
y nadie más va a poder hacer este tipo
de productos y no sólo conmigo
como negocio buena idea
pero lo que nosotros quisimos hacer es
romper un poco ese paradigma entonces es
un proyecto que recién iniciamos tiene
un poco más de una semana la idea es
construir un lugar donde yo pueda tener
máquinas de alta tecnología pero de
acceso a cualquiera
es decir cualquiera puede venir acá y
usar una impresora 3d
se mete en la banda de rock me traicionó
puede usar una impresora 3d o puede usar
una portadora láser puede usar una
máquina controlada por computadora que
puede tallar un rostro en un bloque de
madera cosas así que la industria ahora
es muy celosa en poner un blindaje ahí
de que nadie más puede hacer que para
mis proyectos
nosotros lo democratizamos lo abrimos
cualquiera puede ir y por 20-25 dólares
al mes poder manejar todas las máquinas
que quieras sin restricción que de otra
manera tuviese que incurrir en un costo
muy alto de miles de miles de dólares en
adquirirla es iniciativa la iniciamos
recién
le digo un poco más de una semana aquí
algunas fotos del lugar para que
entiendan un poco que estamos haciendo
eso es una impresora 3d por ejemplo
tenemos equipos de electrónica o si los
propios un taller bastante completo ya
tenemos gente trabajando allí en
proyectos muy interesantes que de otra
manera no lo hubieran podido hacer
hubieran tenido que ir a peregrinar de
fábrica en fábrica tratando de ver bueno
aquí voy a usar lo que se sus
facilidades de inyección de plástico
para hacer la parte plástica acá voy a
hacer la parte de electrónica donde otro
fulano que me da la facilidad de
etcétera y lo mejor ese producto
terminará costando miles de dólares
hasta llegar a su fin aquí es dónde
cuesta 20 entonces es una manera de
compartir tecnología
eso sí todavía no sé cómo va a ir pero
espero que bien y ha habido cierta
cobertura de prensa en poquísimos días
ya fue el diario preso tenemos ya como
1600 creo likes en en facebook
hemos salido este wikipedia alguien ya
no sé qué fue pero alguien puso la
página
elche de gracias y está por aquí la el
evento de apertura fue muy bonito
estudian autoridades el rector del spol
autoridades importantes que compartieron
el sueño nuestro porque es tenemos
sueños o lo mío en un sueño también de
la universidad que
por suerte nos apoyó ciegamente en el
proyecto para finalizar un poco quiero
dejar ese bichito de no necesariamente
cada vez que yo tengo una idea yo tengo
que brindarme porque a veces cuando yo
he visto ese comportamiento nunca se
lleva nada restaurante porque te una
buenísima receta para hacer todo lo que
ha pasado
pero a veces del dicho al hecho hay
mucho trecho no nos damos ese salto al
gran negocio a veces si yo dijera bueno
voy a compartir la receta con todo el
mundo y voy a en el caso del software al
menos voy a dejar que la gente pruebe mi
software de manera sin ningún costo una
vez que ese usuario prueba el software y
se enamora le resuelve un problema de
que es un producto de calidad y les
sirve porque nuestro producto es un
producto empresarial luchas con
productos que valen miles de dólares el
qhapaq a cero
ese usuario dice bueno a es cero mejor
de 30 mil dólares esos 30 mil lo voy a
invertir en educación
y ahora me termina pagando por la
educación de polycia pero igual estamos
haciendo un negocio al final del día
les quiero dejar con el bichito de no
necesariamente el usuario elige el único
a veces el usuario elige el mejor
puede haber muchas opciones en el
momento de compartir muchos nos pueden
copiar pero si somos los mejores siempre
tendremos posibilidad de éxito y es lo
mejor podemos retornar retomar ese
principio que nos enseñaron cuando
éramos niños y continuar compartiendo en
esta vida y en negocio muchas gracias
[Aplausos]